all right you have convinced me that it
is an air to say that Santa Claus does
not exist Santa Claus exists but this
Santa have any potentiality is a
perception intellect or agency apart
from his mystical body that is apart
from the extended body composed of human
beings acting on his personality if no
does the angel of a city have such
potentialities apart from its mystical
body if no - that does Christ have any
such potentialities apart from his
mystical body all right so I think we
need to not stick on the Santa the Santa
image too much
I agree I think that Santa does I think
I could say the Santa Clause does have
potentialities of perception but I would
I would let's use something which is
maybe more easy to understand yeah you
know besides Santa the idea of the city
for example or the angel of a city and
the the question of whether or not a
city has capacities to perceive now now
you have to think of it in terms of when
you think of a person and you have to
understand that a person is also
composed of multiplicities that's that's
something that people always seem to be
forgetting very quickly that a person is
composed of multiple aspects and it's in
that multiplicity that perception
happens and then that perception is
communicated through systems of
communication up to let's say our head
or up to the center of our consciousness
and that's where we then interpret that
perception so for example a a city has
has let's say policeman has you know
employees of the city who work and fix
things have all kinds of employees and
agents but now it's not also agents but
also citizens so the citizens will
perceive things in the city they'll see
that you know oh this there's a swing in
the park on this road that's broken and
then they will communicate that to a
city employee who will communicate that
to
the head of of the department which is
in charge of that and then that head of
the department will check with their
boss if they have the budget to to to
make that change and then the
communication will then go back down
after the perception happens there'll be
a decision at some level in the
hierarchy of the city's consciousness
you would say there'll be a decision
made and then that decision will then
flow down and and will they will or will
not fix the the the swing and if they
fix the swing then that will reach all
the way down to the citizens and the
citizens will be happy that they fix the
swing they don't take the swing that
maybe the citizens will be unhappy so
now you know you can you can link that
to for example a human body you you stub
your toe and it hurts and your toe is
telling you that you got to do something
about this because this hurts now you
can decide that you are not going to do
anything about it
you can totally decide that and you can
just leave it alone
and then maybe in the next day you wake
up and you know your your toenails broke
in and it's infected and and you know
you you're swollen and it's painful and
you can keep you can keep ignoring that
for a while you can totally you can do
that but as you do that you're the part
of you that was communicating to you
that problem is going to to not be happy
and is going to tell you that it's not
happy just in the same way that if you'd
never fix the swing in that neighborhood
then the people of that neighborhood are
going to complain are going to be
annoyed and might um actually you know
do things against you might actually - -
might actually let's say organize - to
take you down or organize things that
will that will challenge the authority
of the the center of consciousness of
that city now a person is the same if
you let it go for a little while
there'll be at some point well you will
not be able to do anything else that
your toe is going to be broken and huge
and swollen and your entire leg
going to get gangrene or whatever like
if you just let it go at some point your
entire being is threatened by the fact
that you ignored the the the sense that
that came out of your big toe and so I
think that that's I think that seeing it
with the city is probably easier than
seeing it with Santa though I think I
think you could probably do similar you
could probably do similar and a similar
analysis with Santa because if you look
at how Santa Claus has changed based on
how the story of Santa Claus has been
received and how Santa Claus has been
has connected with different aspects of
culture becoming now let's say more and
more limited to commercialism and to to
to buying things and so there's a manner
in which the the you know the the core
of Santa Claus is receiving information
from the outside and is actually
changing based on the information that
it receives from the outside so yeah I
hope that answers the question and so it
can help you understand I think I really
want people to be to be careful about
when I talk about these ideas these
ontological categories in these
ontological hierarchies a lot of people
have thought that I'm saying that God is
like Santa and seriously first of all
anybody who's listening to more than a
few videos of mine will know that that
is not what I'm saying
God the notion of God I keep saying
telling God is beyond all word I'll name
all all all concept and so it's only
it's only by very shaky analogy that we
can understand at least that there are
modes of consciousness and modes of
being which are beyond just the
individual and so in in that manner we
then by analogy can start to move up and
understand how that moves up into you
know the infinite itself but I'm not
saying that Santa is is like God so so I
hope that that is helpful